gary kasparov really thrilling us in the
last couple games
and we're wondering can you stick around
and keep playing like that
we have with us third the 13th world
champion gary kasparov
who definitely regaled us with his play
in the last couple of games gary
we saw you in style in the last in the
finish
but i know you wanted to win the match
yes
uh look i was trailing badly but uh i
was in a very good mood and
what's happened today it's i still can't
find explanations it's uh
we spent 29 minutes with peter analyzing
different positions
right we did talk about that on the air
yeah 29 minutes
and then gary showed up and said wait a
second guys are you sure that you know
you're
it's it's the right position yeah i
again i don't want to
to to spread blame but it's uh
actually peter looked at the position i
it's okay my fault
you have to just look at yourself and uh
and i you know i spent all morning
preparing so and i was in very good mood
but you know
i collapsed literally collapsed i mean i
mean
in the first game to play knight d5
instead of 94 i mean it's just i should
be totally
just out of my mind so probably white is
already worse which happened in the
second game
and it's just it was shocking and i um
i i couldn't recover i mean i just i was
you know and then you know at least i
played you know nice combination and
then it's knight xf5
then it blunders again so that's the and
actually the last game was very good
last game yeah that's
that's what i expected to play you know
just normally it's a very nice very
sharp you know sacrificing an exchange
and just creating an attack and then
delivering so as they yeah and even the
game before also was very sharp and very
interesting so again i could trick you
as a castle
so it was the and but but the last one i
again
it's always nice to to to to finish
an event in a high note especially it's
a quality game it's not just a
blunder it's just a nice game so what
we've learned then
you just told me the two things is first
of all you need to check the position
yourself
in 960 you have to check you know you
have to double check because it's just
yeah especially when you have heavy
pieces so yeah so and it's and it's into
it because it's just queen and f1 rook
on g1 just the reverse
it's very interesting because now white
it's top actually
one you know one shift and everything is
different
absolutely just totally everything it is
it's it's not that you can even use the
patterns you
it's absolutely everything just you know
changes you know the geometry
the structures or the way you develop
your pieces and i
but the worst for me actually if i
haven't looked at all
if i came here from the hotel straight
to the game that would be better
but just you know it's you know i just
i don't know i i i want to say one
second can i have you know five minutes
just
no it just survived it's literally a
minute before the game
giri just you know accidentally i mean
otherwise i could peter was saying
peter actually played white you know so
which you know was just you know it's
always better to play white at least you
can probably survive
but i play black and i just you know and
i and again the moment i remember this
when
i didn't i played knight d5 what what
what i'm doing i mean why not
knight goes only four i minutes yeah
that's well and then the second lesson
is
uh maybe we should see more of gary
kasparov flying chess so that you can be
informed
on a regular basis i don't know i just
it's the
it's not not not the greatest moment to
make any promises
but like i can i uh yeah it's it's fun
so i get i'm not here just to
to when i'm here just have fun and just
to to
i think it's being part of the fisher uh
random
it's a first top top uh quality event
uh played in in chess 960 uh
again i'm i'm quite happy that we did
something i believe historical because
uh it's the beginning of a new era and
uh and again
it's just uh innovations uh and
exploration comes from saint louis
well we appreciate that you are leading
the charge with these innovations as
well
and i've heard that you're donating your
twenty thousand dollars your price
winnings to chess in africa as you have
your own foundation there as well
that we also appreciate very well
absolutely yeah look i
i said already uh many times before that
i'm
i'm not a professional amateur so i just
you know i believe that you know
whatever price money i earn i i should
donate them and
as i did last last year so it goes to
africa that's the full
for where it's mostly needed uh again i
have to apologize
for african friends i i expected tonight
ten to the night ten thousand more
yeah but that's the that's probably i
hope that there will be
they'll be gracious and not uh hold me
responsible for not keeping my promise
i'm sure they will in your generosity
your leadership
your novel ideas your role as an
ambassador and fighting for human rights
everywhere
it's very admirable and we thank you
very much for all you do thank you
thank you gary thank you gary i wanted
to ask you gary as
we were arguing um what was your
favorite position of the five
yeah maybe the actually the last one was
most interesting
the last one the they had the positions
here
i remember the positions is the um yeah
they were all again
they're all so different so i i would
say probably the last one was uh
quite entertaining the not the first we
all liked the first one the first one is
yeah it was too nice yes they thank you
tonight yes
i don't like thanks in general so it's
the yeah yeah look again it's it's it
each
i i think the the the the position we
had today again is
it's at um it's it's probably the least
exciting the the first one first
position today
the least exciting so the the last yeah
probably the first one on the last one
yes that would be that would be my my
pick
thank you well we shouldn't say the one
that you looked at with peter
just just reverse
the next life you know so yeah at least
you're well prepared for that one if it
ever shows up i don't know but
the problem is you know this is this
it's in in uh
a few hours you know usually forget what
you do because this again this is
they're so different
so it's the unless you play the whole
tournament so and and that's what my
my my expectation is that eventually
saint louis will start you know
organizing events
where players will have one position for
the entire four or four for the entire
tournament
and then we can see some preparation i
mean that's that would be it's
it's i think it's good to actually see
how they work with computers
so how they just you know integrate uh
chess 916
into the professional chess when they
have time uh
and and uh an opportunity to analyze
with with the computer
gary you'll appreciate this irony uh
maurice described
it today as not peter's finest hour
where he got the position wrong but
peter actually come on the show
and said one of the great joys of this
event was
getting a chance to sit down with you
for an hour before the
event and uh discussing chess
and he discusses the illegal or wrong
position with you for it
it's not illegal it's just yes the irony
is delicious
again at the end of the day it's just
it's it's an important show and i
yes i wanted to win and as again who
knows if if we had the right position
from the beginning
i think i could do better so i i was i
was really in good shape this morning
and i
and i kept improving my performance so
and i had
i have to say have i had high
expectations this morning but
we look forward to seeing you again and
again and again
as it's always a great show when you're
on thank you